many people wrote in to me saying david
did you see
the assassination attempt of the
argentinian vice president christina
kirschner which was caught on video
david you're argentinian
please tell us what you think about this
issue
well i have to tell you and this is
going to anger a lot of people including
even some people in my friends and
family
uh the entire thing stinks to high
heaven that's my honest view so let me
tell you what allegedly happened and
then we're going to kind of dig into it
in more detail
bbc news reports christina kirschner
gunned jams
during bid to kill
argentina vice president
argentina's vice president has narrowly
avoided assassination after a gunman's
weapon jammed as he aimed at her footage
shows the moment that christina found
herself face to face with the loaded
weapon
the former president was outside her
home surrounded by a mob of supporters
who back her in her fight against
corruption charges police said the
gunman identified as a 35 year old
brazilian man had been taken into
custody they're trying to establish
motive the president alberto fernandez
revealed the gun was loaded with five
bullets but failed to fire when
triggered and indeed this was caught on
video
and you see this
it really is incredible video where you
see christina walking around
and all of a sudden a handgun is right
in her face
and then she looks christina looks down
at the floor and it's not clear she
knows what happened and then all of
these security people of which she has
dozens and dozens around her all the
time
run over and then this guy is taken into
custody i have to be really really
honest with you guys to me this stinks
to high heaven and i know many people
don't necessarily follow argentinian
politics and what's going on there uh
christina is a
criminally corrupt individual and there
are major charges against her there's a
corruption trial where a prosecutor is
seeking a 12-year sentence against her
and a lifelong ban from the office uh
from running from holding public office
she says she's the victim of political
pers
persecution prosecution both terms kind
of apply here
and
it is really not looking good for her
now you might remember there was another
prosecutor alberto niesman
who also was moving forward very very
strongly against her with corruption and
other charges and just before
he was going to be presenting evidence
in a court of law
he was found dead of a supposed suicide
now having studied that issue
seriously for many years
i don't believe that niecemann killed
himself it doesn't make any sense when
you understand the full scope of the
story and so now you have another
prosecutor who is bringing serious
charges serious evidence the other day
the president of argentina said i hope
this guy doesn't also kill himself in a
completely dystopian almost putin-like
statement
and then now all of a sudden
despite the fact that christina has
dozens of security people
some
poor brazilian guy
is able to go right up to her
and point a gun right at her head and
there were five bullets in the gun and
oops the gun jammed and christine is
absolutely fine and all of a sudden all
of the attention is on this rather than
the very serious crimes of which
christina is accused so
call me skeptical yes call me skeptical
now
there are people and and by the way i
know people will write in our my
argentinian viewers will say
ludo
you're a mockery guy you're a right
winger no no no no no i think that
mauricio macri
basically argentinian trump
uh was also horrible and did a few good
things did a few good things okay but
not a guy that i supported
the
the the context here is very different
just because i think christina's corrupt
doesn't mean i'm a right winger doesn't
mean i like mockery or whatever
um but to it it all absolutely stinks to
me
so oh and but what i was getting to was
many of the people
who love christina are reacting to
people saying what i'm saying by saying
oh you sick supporter of violence you
want her assassinated
no
no
i don't want anybody assassinated i want
everybody alive and well
and able to face whatever charges are
brought against them in the judicial
system okay so no i'm not advocating for
anyone's assassination so that's my view
on this and to the extent that people in
the audience might be following it
um let me know what you think
real quick
september 19th we are doing it's 9 19
and we are doing a 19 themed membership
special
it's too good to even reveal what it is
so if you've been thinking oh i don't
know maybe i'll get the membership maybe
i'll get access to that bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad yeah if you've
been thinking about that and you've been
waiting for the right opportunity i
suggest the right opportunity is
september 19th where we will be emailing
everybody on our mailing list about this
great membership special if you want to
be notified
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
the only streaming service dedicated to
documentaries is curiosity stream our
longtime sponsor on curiositystream you
will find the best selection of
documentaries better than any other
platform they've got the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles i've been
watching curiosity stream in my living
room i recently watched the six episode
series inside the mind of a con artist
i'm fascinated by scammers and cons and
how they get away with what they do
really great series that i can recommend
to you curiosity stream is always adding
new content they've got documentaries by
filmmakers we know and love but they
make it easy to find new independent
documentaries as well if you want to
absorb as much as you can curiosity
stream is for you if you want to retain
very little once you turn off the tv you
can also just relax with like a nature
documentary curiosity stream has those
too and with the special discount for my
audience you can get curiosity stream
for 15 bucks a year not not a month a
year that's under two bucks a month go
to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below